[Musique]
Truman Show sort sortie en 1998 par
peterware
nous sommes ici sur une réalisation très
poussée très pointue et très calculé
avec à la musique Philip Glass un
compositeur de musique classique qui
apporte ce film à un véritable
enfermement et une recherche justement
de liberté nous avons comme acteur
principal Jim Carrey qui va faire face à
un scénario de Andrew Nicole très très
poussé donc Truman Show le show de
Truman c'est un de la téléréalité de
Truman Truman donc interprété par Jim
Carrey est un acteur qui va être depuis
sa naissance entièrement filmée par des
caméras il ne le sait pas c'est un
enfant c'est un bébé il aura une caméra
juste au dessus de sa tête au dessus de
nous de son landau au début du film et
on va avoir cet enfant fait grandir dans
sa vraie vie tous les gens qui
l'entourent bien évidemment ce sont des
comédiens des acteurs qui vont évoluer
avec lui au fur et à mesure des années
et les spectateurs auront un regard
complètement différent et extérieur à la
situation tout ça
nous amène en fait sur un jean carré qui
est dans un élément complètement
différent de son humour de ses
expressions folles de ces grimaces on
est sur quelqu'un de calme de plus
sérieux de plus poser on va parler
vraiment d'un drame je pense social
[Musique]
se filmer touchant émouvant même
extraordinairement
humain on peut parler d'une ode à la
liberté individuelle une critique de la
téléréalité et de la société
[Musique]